all right what a week our villain of the
day
congresswoman Alexandria Castile Cortes
blaming her growing unfavorability among
Republicans and Democrats on Fox News
tweeting quote it's almost as though
there is a directed far-right propaganda
machine with a whole cable news channel
dedicated to maligning me you have all
the other channels that just love and
support you 24/7 365 all right now have
you started to notice that rather than
defend these radical socialist views
green New Deal the congresswoman spends
most of his time just blaming us for
talking about them and exposing them you
know abolishing oil gas fossil fuels
let's see-oh the combustion engine and
getting rid of planes and cows you know
destroy the economy basically all right
before I go tonight
I want to let you know I had promoted
yesterday and on my radio show today the
judge Jeanine Pirro would be joining us
tonight on the program she had a really
serious family emergency come up
couldn't be with us I don't know the
nature of it but we always pray for her
all right that's all the time we have
left
hope you have a great weekend what a
week this has been we will never be the
destroyed Trump hate media mob and let
not your heart be troubled
we'll see you Monday